to those who don't read comic books
Doctor Strange might seem like a vampire
cape weirdo and he is but for a
character that's existed for 50 years
and comic books and had a made-for-tv
movie about him in the seventies you
should really know the answer to the
question who the heck is dr. strange
Stephen strange indeed didn't start out
as your typical hero as a world-renowned
surgeon he was an arrogant jerk
well on the way to a party at the home
of the wealthiest woman in the state who
happens to be in need of a minor
operation he takes a corner too fast and
his little midlife crisis mobile and
drives off a cliff lacking any magic at
this point he lands harder than he would
have liked and the nerves in his hands
are damaged
he is told he would never again regain
his plus 5 surgeon hands of steadiness i
know i mixed genres there but this guy
is a sorcerer instead of taking his
shaky hands and money and retiring
strange pours his fortune and failed
corrective operations to fix his hands
while wandering dejectedly one day all
of his money spent
he eavesdrops on an extremely credible
source a couple of sailors he doesn't
know talking about an ancient one who
can perform real magic cure any ailment
and Doctor Strange believes it with the
last of his money he travels to Tibet
makes it across the Himalayas and
actually finds you out ancient one
he does all of this without google maps
the doctor is still an arrogant dick at
this point i'll be it with unsteady
hands but eventually he breaks down and
begs you to teach him now has another
pupil though
Mordo who as it turns out wants to
betray his master strange tries to stop
and more dough puts an enchantment on
them which is probably removed by the
ancient one
conveniently though moro space in the
class is opened up and now begins
teaching Stephen he eventually learns
enough to become the sorcerer supreme
which is the protector of the earth
against all magical danger
alright let's talk gear his red cloak is
called the cloak of levitation its
powers include damage resistance
shape-changing and the ability to act as
an extra limb
oh and the levitation park local
levitation I thought you would get that
he also wears the eye of agamotto around
his neck
it's a mystical item that lets him read
minds see through illusions and shoot
beams against
forces magic missile there's also a
theory floating around the eye of
agamotto might be one of the Infinity
stones strange also uses the orb of
agamotto which is kinda like the cerebro
of the magical realm to find people in
things strange builds his house on a
native ritual site in Greenwich Village
New York he calls the house the sanctum
sanctorum because it was the sixties and
that sounded cool
dr. strange as the sorcerer supreme has
become one of Marvel's most powerful
heroes with his exposure growing in
mainstream media it's only a matter of
time before everyone starts using his
catchphrase by the hoary hosts of Hogan
off
I mean it's possible for more your
favorite comic books TV shows and movies
checkout gamespot universe